j'ai commencé à microdoser vraiment pour
calmer mon anxiété
moi-même avec les champignons qu'avec
les antidépresseurs on parle
de une dixième du quantité je vais pas
me sentir basé je veux juste être
capable d'être dans le moment présent
micro doser des champignons magiques une
tendance qui commence à s'installer par
les uns à Roxane Néron on prend pas des
micro doses à toutes les jours
bachelière en sexologie et après
plusieurs années à utiliser des petites
quantités de champignons magiques pour
calmer son anxiété elle a décidé de
lancer un service d'accompagnement mon
service de consultation c'est oui en
micronosage mais c'est aussi en
mieux-être c'est souvent des gens en
fait qui vont vouloir trouver une autre
alternative aux antidépresseurs des gens
comme Yves André bien qu'il ne l'est pas
consulté quand j'ai commencé à faire une
dépression maintenant j'avais à peu près
60 ans
âgé de 80 ans il a décidé d'essayer de
troquer les antidépresseurs pour les
champignons magiques après en avoir
discuté avec sa médecin de famille trois
mois passés et j'ai vu aucune différence
avec des Antilles de dressage j'étais
très bien jusqu'à
tant que lui-même
alors là
vraiment incroyable mais c'est compliqué
compliqué parce que justement
l'environnement contrôlé est important
la dose aussi les thérapies assistées à
la psilocybine sont réalisées avec des
quantités qui sont loin du micro dosage
mon expérience professionnelle avec la
psylosbins des doses ce qu'on appelle
des macrosses docteur Stéphan a lui
aussi assisté des patients pour traiter
la détresse existentielle en fin de vie
une sessions en soins palliatifs qui ont
qui ont été fait monde des améliorations
d'environ 60 à 80% de taux de réponse et
taux de rémission au niveau des
symptômes anxieux-dépressifs chez cette
population là donc clairement ça ça
gagne à être mieux connu là où les
études sont moins concluantes c'est par
rapport au micro dosage où on est la
science sur le micro dosage on est loin
de la certitude là-dessus pas vraiment
de déçu qui explorent cette approche là
correctement encore
idéalement on va en voir dans les
prochains années parce que oui il y a du
potentiel mais non dire que c'est
quelque chose de prouver actuellement
pourtant l'engouement est réel
geoffrandeuse affirme que beaucoup
patient lui pose des questions sur le
micro dosage moi je recommande pas
c'est son illégales mais les gens qui
vont décider de faire ça eux-mêmes moi
je prends un rôle de éducateur parce
qu'il existe tout de même des risques il
y a des risques de base de nausées mal
de tête anxiété exacerbées pendant
l'expérience après ça les risques les
plus inquiétants mais qu'on a pas
vraiment vu ressortir dans les études ce
serait des risques de
développer ou révéler une maladie de
l'ordre psychotique c'est la moins
risqué des substances parce qu'il y a
pas de risque vraiment de dépendance
Jean-Sébastien fall
u la légalisation des champignons
magiques approche c'est une substance
moins risquée plus acceptée socialement
s'exclamment la prochaine avec légalisé
mais que ce soit pour un usage macro
médical ou un micro dosage récréatif il
faut davantage d'études davantage
d'informations ça me fait peur que on
comprend pas nécessairement tout ce
qu'il faut pour faire ça de façon
sécuritaire d'après moi ça reste des
substances extrêmement prometteuses au
niveau de la santé mentale au niveau
psychiatrique qui sont mettons
sous-financés par rapport à leur
potentiel même après son expérience
infructueuse
lui est prêt à réessayer bientôt là je
sais pas car bientôt je vais recommencer
mais je voudrais que ce soit un produit
de qualité de toute façon je suis 80 ans
mais rien que ça à faire des essais